[拍手]
ある
みなさんこんにちは
英語2番目のプレゼンターを務めさせて頂く館の流儀ですよろしくお願いします
そして最初にですね
x という足湯ティ今回初開催ということで1年間
粘り強く頑張ったオーガナイズの皆さんに賞賛を贈りたいと思います
おめでとうございます
[拍手]
あっ遅かったですね見ますエプですね
今日はのなんで僕がここに来たかというところからお話をしたいと思うんですけれども
僕はですね
先ほど紹介にあったようにあのどういう橋技科大の卒業生ではありません
またですね豊橋市民でもありません
なのでちょっと部外者っぽいところもあるんですけれども
紹介にあった通りおくといいですねユーティが強いつながりがあってですねこうせん
ですね
皆木課題の皆さん技科大の皆さん敵をどれぐらいいらっしゃいますか
ちょろちょろ言いますありがとうございますが他の皆さんの7割8割は高専卒だと思う
んですけれども
あとで出るんですけど僕も東京高専卒業生です
今はですね10年ほど社会人経験を積みながらこう選挙で教育という
高専生向けのニッチは教育をしているんですけれどもまあ今日はそれに則った話をし
たいなと思いながらその他の会場の皆さんも沢山いらっしゃいますので
豊泉であったり ut という枠にとらわれずに一つですね
僕のプレゼンのコンセプトワードを決め
ました
きゅうりやつ
応答のテッドのムービーでもあったんですけども curious という単語があり
ます
これは何かというとそのまま意訳するとですね好奇心旺盛なという表現になるんです
けれども
どちらかと言うと9やすな人という定義は僕はですね
興味関心を持ったものを持ったときにそこにぎゅっとフォーカスをしてそして強い
パッション情熱そしてスキル
そういったものを注ぎ込んで物事を推進できるそういった才能を持った人のことを休養
しな人だと思っています
これはですね可愛らしい逆て弱点もあってですね逆に捉えると自分が興味関心を持って
いないものあるいは興味関心を失ってしまった時にですね
ものすごい推進力が落ちてしまっているそういった可愛らしい決定を持った人を今日は
旧安の人と表現したいと思います
なんでこのテーマにしたかというとですね僕自身もそうなんですけれども
豊泉であったり ut にはそういう人はたくさんいるんじゃないかという仮説を僕は
持っています
後半ではそれを実験したいと思うんですけれども今日はですね
タイトルはこれですねピンク中に中濃てサーフィ恩給ちゃ
と自分自身の人生を歩むためのコツギター話をしたいんですけれども
俺は山に戻ってございましだと思いますあああ
9レースなと
自分自身本当に競技を持ったことに妥協は四元素そういう
それ以外の事はちょっと見分けないとそういった人が良いそうですね自分自身の人生
きちんと火つけるでそこに邁進することそれが非常に重要なんですね
この世を主に旧やつな方に向けて人生を生きるコツ
それを2あの伝えていきたいと思っています
て最初にですね結論を出したいと思います
今日の穴が3つありますひとつふぁいなぁ冬エリア
と自分自身が本当は何者なのかどこに対して自分は興味関心を持てるのかそういった
ことを理解することがまず大事です
次に
というは choo ed want you 位これもそうですね本当にやりたい事
以外の事は皆さん
キュビオスな人は苦手ですなので本当にやりたいことを見つけてそれをやってください
そして3つ目
bd オーナー帯やオンライン
当たり前ですね自分がやりたいことをやるんですから自分のその責任結果プロセス
リスク
そういったもの自分自身の人生のものとしてきちんと受け入れましょう
今日はこういった結論に向かって話を進めていきたいと思うんですけれども
東えりか大生が今日はたくさんいますよね
人生とかキャリアとかそういう話をしたいんですけれども
まだほとんどの人は社会に出たことがない与えたことも転職したこともない
あるいは結婚したり子供が生まれたりそういった経験がない方が多いと思いますので
今日は最初にですねひとつのケースとして僕自身の人生を振り返り
まあその中でどんな葛藤があったのかそして今どういう状態なのか
それを最初にシェアしたいと思っています
結構ですね恥ずかしい話もあるんですけど勇気を出して喋りたいと思います
僕自身は自分が旧安人間だと思っています
昔からですね興味関心をもって思いはどんどん突っ込んでしまいますしそういった時に
はかなりのパワーを発揮してやっぱりそういう時に人から言われるんですね
come the すごく情熱的だねファッションがあるねすごいねと
そうじゃないときもあるんですけども僕は旧良質な人間だと思っています
重い社会に出てからですねこの10年間僕は大きなトラブルを実は抱え続けてきたんだ
ということに最近気づきました
起点はここになるんですけど僕は1999年に東京高生入学し
の後東京工業大学で分子生物学を学んでいました
豊泉に行った時にですね化け学を学んでたんですけれどもある時ですね
リチャードドーキンスの立法的な遺伝子という生物進化の本を読みまして
これは美しいアルゴリズムだとこれはカッコイイ
研究者というのかっこいいや世界にまだない知識事実生み出して歴史に何を残す
裏かっこいいじゃないこということですね僕は研究者になろうと抜き
夢を月日そして東京工業大学で8買って3年まで研究をしていました
当選品研究者になりたかったのでグローバルクラスになりたい
海外に研究留学行ったんですね半年か日本人が誰もいないところで研究流をもしました
し
国際学会でプレゼンの発表もしました
あんですけれども細かい話を置いておくんですけども
ここでやっぱり挫折をしたんですね
で越河研究者にはならなかったんですけれども
牛が非常にですで問題で研究が嫌いとか研究ができないじゃなかったんですよ
これ後でですね石田先生という方が床暖れっ子シート研究の粘り強さについてお話しし
てくださると思うんですけれども
岡中アカデミックの世界を見ていてよくあるじゃないですか
例えばですね学生もわかると思うんですかケーキ
取り合いとおい政治がいろいろある
上が詰まっているんでこうポストが開かない商品のレースもやっぱりアリウム
教授同士のパワーバランスにいろいろあるじゃないですか
本当に研究好きだったその後気にせず頑張ろうぜという話なんですけど僕はそこで何か
家にしちゃったんですよね
僕政治よく全然ないのでちょっとこれはしんどいなと
っていうことで
六パートをしてしまいます
で
今思うとこの理由て凄くダサいなと思うんですけどまぁとにかく僕はドロップアウトし
て
なので社会に出たんですね
その後の10年間の僕のキャリアはですねこれです
ばいくつかパック未問題があると思うんですけれども
一番大きな問題は
数ですよねはずです10年間に誠リストが8個あるんですけれども僕6回ですねこの
10年間で会社を辞めているんですね
いろいろ理由はあるんですけどもとにかく2年以上同じ仕事を粘り強くすることが出来
ないような人間になってしまったんです
結果として
おっ改正問題で深刻さを伝えていきたいんですけども各社です
非常に素晴らしい会社が並んでるんですねで僕は結構ですね
仕事ができた方でして例えば
菅野さんはこの会社のこの事業の大黒柱だと言われたこともありますし
反応さんには役員になってほしいエンチャキーをちっちゃいんでとか
反応さんみたいなとんがっててちょっと変わってるんだけどエネルギーある人はこの
会社支えてくれるんだろうなぁって尊敬する上司に言われたこともあるんですね
それほどの期待値を持ちながらでもなんか僕は些細なことでなんかやめてしまうそう
いう曲を持ってしまっていました
ぴ快都ですね奥今でも研究者に多分なりたいんですよね
てその夢を下らないいうで諦めてしまったその時に自分自身の高
何者なのかどこに興味関心があるのかそして本当にやりたいことなんだってっていうの
をロストしてしまったんですね
誰しもこういう経験ってあると思うんですけども飛距離が質な人っていうのはこれを
失うとこうなってしまうんだと
いうことを僕は振り返って感じていました
さらにですねものすごい深刻な問題があって
お母さんのかと言いますか
これから本当に頭を下げないといけないんですけど実は僕も結婚していまして
子供がいます
さらに言うという3人いるんですね
これはの本当に冊今感じているところなんですけれども
子供産むたびに転職する夫ふらふらふらふら転職スロート
まずいですよねあら at なが非常に深刻な事態なんですよ人生において
それぐらいでもなんか僕は気に食わないことが2件食してしまう
なんかそういう人間になってしまったんですね
今振り返るといろいろ覚えことがあるんですけどとにかくそういう結構ドツボというか
人生破綻寸前みたいな所まで行っていました
ここで話が終わるとですねあかんのさん反面教師にして頑張って生きていこうと皆さん
に思っていただけるんですけれども
&ですねこれがちょっと復調してきたんですね
そこを皆さんに伝えたくて
あの
きっかけがあったんです
今僕の息子は7歳小学1年生なんですけれども
12歳の声ですね息子を見てて
あの思っちゃったんですよ
僕にそっくりだなと
なんでもかんでも手を出してしまう子を重ね和解と思い何でもかんで体だしちゃう
love ないこと平気でやっちゃったり
良いことも悪いこともバンバンやっちゃったちょっと扱いづらいですよね僕の息子って
もすごい僕に入ってそうなんですよ
さらに最近小学生でまぁ最近のビッグイシューの一つにハヤブサツァイト母に
タッチダウンをしたと言う
皆さん君たと思うんですけども
あれを見てですね家に帰るんです家に帰ると息子がですね
俺なんだってなんか見せてきたんですね
オール神と折り紙で作ったはやぶさ2なんですけどこれが面白いのがあの知ってる人
知ってると思うんだな
ソーラーパネルって可動式じゃないですか
まずはちっちゃいおもちゃモデル設けませんちゃんと可動式なんです
なるほど
あのインパクトのところあるじゃ誰もちゃんと可動式なんです
なかなかこだわる小1やな思うんですねそうするとで暑い日させてリビングなんですね
あれが竜宮っていうあるんですよ段ボールで作った竜宮らして変な物体がですねズレさ
れているんです
あれがタイヤ対応も作ったのかと
でもかちょっと質問してみたんです
地球から太陽まで光の速さで言ったら何分だと思う
小学校というお父さんに言われた父親もエンジニア6
行ったんですよ8分19秒
なるほどとっ
高専出身の方へ入り t のかでもわかるこれはもう人生一択なんです
豊泉に行ったら幸せになる普通高校に入った絶対うまえやばいと
もうほかも in 中傷です直感が僕は働いてしまって後世に入れたいと思う
僕は光線を愛していますただ問題があったんです
公正性これも言っていいのか誰もわかると思うんですけれども構成成功選定
こんなに愛してるんですけどどんなか誰も知らないような学校なんですよ
最近やっとロボ君の学校ぐらいですよ
なので非常に貴重なイノベーティブな人材がたくさんいるはずなのに誰も知らないから
例えば給料が安い
例えば昇進機会が少ない僕の友達もそうなんですよ
そういうことはやっぱり怒ってしまうという負の側面もあってですね
選択肢は2つあるんですねそれだったちょっと普通膀胱がんばつ進学校行って東工大と
か当然方がくびれるかと
いや僕は公正性なのに違うんです無いものは作ると宝泉圧倒的ブランドを作るに作って
息子絶対に入れたいと思ってですね
なので今高専キャリア教育というですね事業
2年間継続してですねそのブランド社会に伝えたいという活動をしていますん
何が起こったかというとですねこの活動をすごいのが息子1歳2歳で思って今7歳です
ん
国は5年間ですねまったくお金にまだなって薄めやっとちょっとお金出てきたらやっぱ
最近会社作ったぐらいはこのうち事ですね
5年間僕が続けているんですよ
いましたさっきの僕のリスト
あーの母のさんがこうなるんだと
きっかけはもちろん息子なんですけれどもやっぱりきちんと振り返るとですね
息子見ることによって僕は
あのか全然いいんだと
いうことを通じておそらく自分を承認できたんですよね
そして
これがきっかけであるんですけれども高専ってやっぱり僕の人生の原点なんです
結構みんなそうだと思い
本当にやりたいことというにをきちんと見つけることができてそしてそこに対して
色んな人が色々入ってきますよ5年間もいろいろやってくると
でもやっぱり粘り強くやるんです
えっ
5年やっているとですね凄いのが例えばあの
知ってる人は知っているとか東大に松尾先生という
ai 研究第12社がいるんですけど挑戦青和高専見つけている
で今度で4月にあるんですねあの文科省とか経産省とか日系巻き込んで
高専向けのディープランディングのコンテストが開かれるん
ただ僕はたまたも声がけしていただいて準備質問に入っているんですけどそんなことが
ある
各ベンチャーも10年もいいと各ベンチャーが僕に校正さ欲しいって言ってくる
でもっている最近ですね某あのソフトバンクの某社長室の方から連絡があってです
方選手は本当にすごい温泉バンバン起業させてアソコ wii ワープって言うで世界
てにプレイ君はあの
コラボレーションスペースを運営しているどんどん良いバッグに入れてくれて協力する
から
いう話が来たりするんです
こんな事が起こる人生では先までなかったんですけどこういうことがあっ
えええ
なにが言いたい事いいですね q 明日の人は世の中にたまにいるんですね
て
多かれ少なかれ学生でも社会人でもそうなんですよ
ちょっと一杯苦手なことがぶつかったりとか人より結構センシティブにそういうところ
でつまずいてしまうことがあると思うんですけど
僕は多分大丈夫だと思うんですたとえどんなにつまずいても旧来その人は自分の人生の
目的
やりたいことを見つければ100%の確率で最高の犬データに復活できると思ってい
ます
きっと僕と似たような悩みを若い人も年を取ったしてもが生えている人はいると思うん
ですよ
ただ僕は大丈夫だと言いたい
これが一つ目のメッセージ
ちょっと時間が足りないのでパパっていきたいんですけどもところでですね
僕はちょっと証明したいことがいっぱいあるので実験に付き合ってください
ut
これは高生の先輩で以上いう語感の濃縮ず見たいところだと思うんですけど
いや僕はこの人たちは結構きゅうりツナ1な濃縮じゃねぇかなと思っているんですね
なのでちょっと実験を指しています8技科大生先生
あれは高生の方々手を挙げないでください
その対比としてみませんもう終わりのでガチャを上げていただいていいでした
ん
はいありがとうございます
あもうちょっと千葉影ですで質問をさせていただきます
あの九尾明日な人というのは
ちょっとね人とは違うけど特別な才能があるを持っている人です
何かというとその辺に住んなにいるわけじゃないんですよ
なので質問ですあなた自身あるいはあなたの周りに
軽く1220 new がこの人旧安田なーって思う人がいると思った方は今パッと
思いついた片手を上げ続けてください
そうじゃない方は手を下ろしてください
ありがとうございます
これた場合あっ大丈夫ですよだから今日意識高い方が多いんで
手を上げる品の方飼っ
はいじゃあ今度技科大指定
高専生の先生方もお願い同じ質問です
q ラスな人というのはそんなに世の中にたくさんいるもんじゃないんです
さっき1220結構で上がっちゃったねじゃんくらすぎが暮らすとか学校に
に32軽く9やすな人がいるなあと友達ですよと
750でもいいです
俺の周り大耐久レースだなって思う人はそのまま手を上げ続けてください
そうじゃない人でおろしっ
何か体を下ろします
前々のほうとくオーガナイザーも全員あれです
手を挙げていますありがとうございません
でちょっと今日はですね皆さん非常にアクティブな方だったので坂であんまり出なかっ
たんですけれども僕はですね
ut 構成でものすごく特集だと思うんですねそれは技術を学ぶということに関しての
トピ主さんも当然あるんですけれども
何を椅子が給油明日な人間が集まってきて
それを園パー面子する自由に物を作ろうやりたいことやろうよと言ってくれる先生
そして環境があるというのがこの国で他の大学や高校とかで全く違う所なんじゃないか
ということを僕は信じてそれを証明したいと思い
day
そういう人たちって
あの
良い悪いじゃないんですけどイノベーションという領域にすごくフィットしてるんです
よね
将来わかんない確率的に当たるかどうかもかんでもとにかくやってみなきゃやってみる
とわかんないんだそういうことをやれる素質をですね
you チーンの皆さん法政の皆さん持っていると思っています
なのですねとはいってもキュウリ明日の人っていうのはいろいろ問題があるわけです
人生に
普通の人は直家があるんですけどでも僕は皆さんもほとんどイノベーターだし
いうちーな存在じゃあもうイノベーションだと思うので
そこをどんどんエンハンスしていきたいと思っています
pq です
で最後にですね
あっ結論過ぎちゃいます最後に一つだけ今日は旧や質な人という
のメッセージ性を込めたプレゼンをさせていただいたんですけれども
僕自身もそうなんですけれども
救出な人というのは飛距離チャレンジングガウンですね
すぐ転んじゃんですねっ
っていう小欄でケガをしてしまっ
いたいなぁと思っ
で僕はやっぱりいろんな人に支えていただいて
あとが復活して
がんばれていく
なので誰がいいとか悪いじゃなくていろんな人がお互いの特性を理解して
ともにですね未来を乗り切る未来を乗り越えますよ
そういった関係性パートナーシップコミュニティーを問えばこの会場皆さん
この社会みんなで着たらすごく楽しいんじゃないかなと思っていますありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]